[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today starting
off this hour is Corey in Cleveland Ohio
hi Corey how are you good how you doing
better than I deserve what's up so I got
a question I I got $35,000 in credit
card debt I'm going through a divorce uh
she wants me to take another half of
hers and I um I I'm struggling I'm
working um five days a week um I drive
truck as a local truck driver and I just
don't know where to where even to start
at
okay
um how much debt do you guys have as a
couple you've got 35 how much does she
have it'll be 65,000 total so she has
another 30 yes okay and there car
payments uh yes I have a car payment my
my truck payment is 970 a month good God
all right
and um how much is her car
payment uh her car payment I'm not too
sure of that we're actually we're going
through a divorce and we're separated at
this
time well dude you were married to her
did you have the car
then yeah yeah well she had uh she had
given me my car back I had bought her a
Lexus at the time and she had gave it
back to me stuck me with that and my
truck payment plus a motorcycle payment
and I was struggling so I traded both of
my vehicles in and end up purchasing the
truck I have now I save myself about
$500 a month doing that yeah you didn't
go far enough all right no I didn't all
right
um okay so the problem is is we're
working out all the debts before there's
a deal
cut so every time you every time you get
something paid off or figured out she
hands you another one yes now this has
got to
stop you've already eaten a Lexus in a
motorcycle and now she wants you to eat
15 more of the debt that's the credit
card debt that's in her name yes okay so
we need to uh do you guys have an
attorney yeah we have we both have
attorneys I I tried ton her I I she keep
the house and everything we put into it
she keeps her Deb I keep mine we'll go
our separate way and she's not into it
uh she has no she's not willing to work
with me at
all okay then I guess the judge is going
to have to decide right and that goes
February 7th and trying to figure out
what I need to do in the meantime I have
an opportunity right now to buy my own
semi and go over the road and make what
I'm making now you need to get this
cleared up before you do that because
she's goingon to end up with half the
dad gum semi right that's what I'm
worried about yeah how much money do you
have in the
bank uh at this moment in time I'm
struggling and that's what I'm uh I have
maybe 30 bucks right now I'm going
through it right
now
okay and you're not driving over the
road now or you are
you just cut out on me man oh that's why
we were uh that's why we're going to the
divorce we drove team over the road
together me and her together uh we were
racking down 250,000 a year between us
both um I was sticking mine in my 401k
she was spending hers and that's another
thing she's wanting she's wanting half
of my 401k also and we weren't even
married that long three years and she's
entitled to uh everything put in from
the date of marriage to the date of
divorce which is it's not even it's not
really a lot of money but I worked for
it you know you guys have kids no kids
NOP okay so are you driving over the
road now no I'm local okay what do you
make uh right now I'm 3322 an hour and
that is all straight pay and you've got
an apartment yes okay what's the house
worth uh I just had an appra at a price
for
174,000 what do you owe on
it uh
132 okay all right so here's here's what
I would do all right the problem with a
divorce is it turns a marriage into a
business
transaction and so this is now a list of
debts and a list of assets that must be
negotiated through the law in Most
states as you have found out splits it
down the middle what she wants doesn't
matter what you want doesn't matter the
law is going to demand that you split it
down the middle if you come to something
close to that and pre- agree to it the
judge will approve it if you come to
something way out of balance the judge
is probably not going to approve it and
kick out your agreed to settlement
because it's too
stupid okay so all of that to say you
don't need to be buying anything if I
were in your shoes I'd sell this truck
yeah get you yeah you said that like I'm
not doing it you need to sell your
stupid truck dude $970 at $33 an hour is
in the cray cray zone right I I want to
get rid of it I went to trade it in they
told me I would have to pay out $4,000
in equity negative equity to could get
off from underneath the truck at that
point go go borrow 4,000 at the credit
union and do it or sell a private party
if you can make 4,000 more and be get
out of it clean sell it private and and
just sell it and be done with it
somebody will give you more than you owe
on it okay what is it what kind of truck
is it it's a 2023 Chevy
Silverado that's a beast that's a good
Truck Yeah you ought to be able to get
more than you owe on it yeah so yeah the
problem is the dealer thinks he's got
you coming
again right he got you last time he's
going to get you again especially if
you're desperate they can smell that off
you yeah so I think I think you put it
on the look it up on Kelly Blue Book and
sell it for more than you owe on it and
then get you a hoopy because you're
driving truck during the day anyway you
don't need a bank big car right now you
got more problems than you need car
right yes sir so this is temporary one
year from the day everything's going to
be changed but temporarily you've gotten
rid of the car now you're down to only
$35,000 worth a credit card debt and
negotiating with your soon toe ex-wife
over the 401K in the house yes because
the credit card debts going to be split
down the middle you're going to get your
35 she's going to get her 30 you're
probably going to give up half your 401k
or you can give her a credit towards the
house and sell the
house right how much is in the
401K uh 35 35,000 so 17 of the equity in
the house can go to her instead of
giving up your 401k and sell the house
and give her her half plus 17 which is
probably almost the whole thing but
don't let the house stay in the deal do
not do not let her have the house cuz
you're on the mortgage and then she
doesn't pay it you're
screwed right Force the sale of the
house split the proceeds minus your half
of the 401K that you're going to have to
give up anyway and that way your 401k
stays
intact you walk out of this with a 401k
and only $335,000 worth a credit card
debt and a hoopie now you can talk about
going over the
road and making some money and clean up
the $ 35,000 right
quick okay but you're being managed by
emotion because your heart's broken one
minute you're pissed the next minute and
you're brok and terrified the next
minute yes sir understand man I've been
there it's no fun and so I I hav been
through the divorce part of it been
through the rest of it though and it is
no fun so laying out a detailed factual
game plan with math removes some of the
emotion from it and that's what I just
gave you so go back and listen to this
on YouTube or on podcast or however so I
cuz I gave you the exact plan of what to
do
and and what I what I laid out is
negotiable and if she won't do it take
it before the judge he'll make her do it